최근에 세계 3대 부동산 개발 기업인
하인스 비롯한 mng 그리고 이제
모건스탠리 등 글로벌 기업들이 한국
부동산 그중에서도 주거용 부동산을
투자하기 위해서 한국의 돈을 싸들고
오고 있습니다 과연이 기업들이 왜
한국부동산 주거용 부동산을 투자하려고
하는지 이유네 가지를 좀 설명드리자면
일단 첫 번째로 1인 가구들이 많이
증가하고 있어요 그래서 2022년도
아지만 해도 한 60% 정도 됐던
1인 가구가 1년 만에 한 70%
10% 정도가 늘어났습니다 그리고
올해 같은 경우에도 아마 더 늘어날
것으로 예상이 돼요 가구수 구성에
대한 변화 때문에 앞으로 이제 전세
수요는 좀 더 줄어들고 월세 수요
그러니까 1인 가고 수요는 더 많아질
것으로 예상이 되기 때문에 그런
부분에서 좀 매력을 느꼈던 거
같습니다 그리고 두 번째로 전세사기
때문에 월세 선호 현상이 되게 많이
늘어났습니다 세입자들은 안정성을 되게
중요하게 생각하게 됐고 기업이 직접
소유한 그런 부동산의 월세 수요가 더
많아질 것으로 예상이 됩니다지
우리나라 같은 경우에는 한 96%
정도이 주거용 부동산을 소유하고
있어요 개인이 소유하고 있으면은
이슈들이 많이 발생되거나 무슨
가압류가 당하거나 채무가 많이
걸리거나 이런 문제 때문에 전세
사기도 발생되고 전세금을 못 돌려
주는 그런 상황들이 발생되는데
우리나라의 이런 기업들이 소유한
부동산이 주거용 부동산이 한 3%
정도밖에 안 됩니다 그래서 비율이
매우 낮아요 그래서 그런 점 때문에
전세금에 대한 리스크가 되게 커집니다
근데 아무래도 기업이 소유하다 보면
기업은 그런 리스크가 상대적으로 좀
적거든요 임차인 같은 경우에는이
개인이 소유하는 것보다는 이런
기업들이 소유하고 있는 그런 주거용
부동산 선호 현상이 더 커질 것으로
예상이 되기 때문에 그런 점에 좀
이유를 되는 거 같습니다 그리고 일본
같은 경우에도 개인이 소유한 거보다
이런 기업이 소유한 비율이 되게
높거든요 그래서 예를 들어서 뭐 뭐
미스의 부동산이 소유하고 있는 주거용
건물이라는 이런 건물 같은 경우에는
운영이나 관리도 되게 체계적으로 잘
되거든요 그러다 보니까 월세 임대료가
되게 높게 받습니다 근데 우리나라
같은 경우에는 아무래도 개인이 많다
보니까 이런 관리나 운영이 좀
체계적으로 돼 있지가 않아요 그래서
임대료가 좀 그런 점 때문에 적었던
부분도 있고 근데 제 생각엔 앞으로
우리나라가 이런 기업들이 많이
들어오게 된다면 그런 관리나 운영이
좀 체계적으로 잘 될 거 같아요
임대료 수준도 되게 높아 질 것으로
예상이 됩니다 그리고 세 번째로는
그런 정부에서 이런 지원을 많이
하려고 해요 아무래도 이런 주거
시설이 많이 부족하다 보니까 이런
기업용 임대 주택에 대한 뭔가 세금
혜택이라는 이런 임대로 규제를
없앤다는 뉴스들이 좀 많이 나오고
있거든요 이런 세제 혜택이라는
정부에서도 좀 밀어주는 부분도 있기
때문에 그런 점에서 좀 매력을 느꼈던
거 같습니다 그 마지막으로네 번째로
글로벌 부동산에 대한 시장에 좀
변화인데 코로나 이후에 이런 오피스
수요가 많이 줄었거든요 그러다 보니까
공실률이 많이 늘어났고 그래서 외국
자본이 좀 새로운 투자처를 좀 찾고
있어요 아무래도 우리 한국 임대주택이
이런 1인 가고도 증가하고 있고
그다음에 세제 혜택도 있고 그리고
전세 때문에 임대료가 억눌려 있었는데
그거를 올릴 여지도 있었기 때문에
이런 외국계 기업들이 우리나라 시장에
대한 매력을 좀 느껴 가지고 이렇게
하지 않았나 이렇게 생각을 합니다네
한국은 전 세계 적으로 유일하게 전세
제도가 있습니다 한국의 임대료 수준을
세계 주요 도시와 비교했을 때 정말
저렴해요 진짜 전세가 억누르고
있었거든요네 그러다 보니까 세계 주요
도시와 비교해서 우리나라 임대료가
진짜 상대적으로 많이났습니다 다른
세계적인 도시와 비교해도 진짜 월등이
저렴합니다 하지만 서울 직각 같은
경우에는 세계적인 도시와 비교했을 때
되게 높은 편이에요 근데 임대료는
제일 낮습니다 그래서 좀 되게 균형이
안 맞는 어 그런 지금 시장에 있는데
이런 점 때문에 글로벌 기업들이 전세
때문에 억눌려 있었던 이런 임대료
상승 가능성이 되게 높고 전세가
없어지고 월세로 전환되는 지금 시점이
든요 지금 시기에 진입하면 좋겠다라는
판단을 하고 이런 글로벌 기업들이
한국 주거 시장에 좀 들어온 부분이
있는 거 같습니다 현재 지금 리테일
시장이나 오피스 시장이 좀 좋지
않습니다 되데만 되고 안 되는 데는
안 돼요 그리고 전체적으로 봤을 때는
지금 자영업자 폐업률이 그지 지금
오피스 공실률이 매우 높아요 이런
상업용 부동산은 확실한 거 아니면은
투자를 권하진 않습니다 근데 그거와
반에이 주거에 대한 수요는 많아요
그리고 예를 들어서 강남 같은 경우에
아무리 면이라도 주거에 대한 수요가
많습니다 직장이 아무래도 강남에 많다
보니까 이런 직장의 수요가 굉장히 좀
많이 있어요 이렇게만 보면 주거
시장이 되게 매력적이긴 하지만 아직
우리나라의 그 주거에 대한 세금
이슈가 너무 큽니다 제가 개인으로
매입할 경우에 주택을 추가적으로
매입하면 취득세 증가가 되기도 하고
종합 부동산세를 내기도 하고 만약에
법인으로 주택을 취득하면 취득세가
무려 13.2% 만약에 건물을 매입할
경우에는 관리에 대한 이슈도 있긴
하거든요 좀 좋은 조건은 안 돼 있는
거 같아요 제가 말씀드린 주거용
부동산은 아파트가 아니라 이런 다가구
주택 다세대 주택 뭐 이런 걸
말씀드리는 거예요 우리나라는 세금적인
이슈 때문에 의 이런 주거용 부동산을
투자하기에는 아직까지 좀 좋지
않습니다 그리고 또 주거용 시장의
단점이 뭐냐면 우리나라 같은 경우에는
방 하나당 최우선 변제금을 공제해
줍니다 그래서 대출이 안 나와요
그래서 그 지역마다 최우선 변제금이
있는데 그거를 제외하고 대출을 해
줘요 그래서 방이 엄청 많은 이런
주거용 건물 같은 경우에는 대출이 안
나옵니다 뭐 미국 같은 경우에는
이런게 없거든요 아무래도 뭐 대출
규제도 없지 뭐 이렇게 관리에 대한
이슈도 없지 뭐 이거 종부세를 내
되는 경우는 엄청 큰 건물이지 그리고
취득세가 증가되는 것도 없지 뭐 그런
점 때문에 현 시점으로 봤을 때는
이런 대출 규제라는 뭐 세금 이슈라는
이런게 없기 때문에 상업용 부동산이
좀 더 매력적이지 않나 저는
개인적으로 그렇게 생각합니다네 종합해
보면 상업용 부동산은 지금 임대
시장이 좋지 않기 때문에 그리고
앞으로 금리가 떨어져도 단기간에
좋아질 것 같지는 않습니다 주거용
부동산 시장에도 여러분들이 좀 관심을
가지시면 좋을 거 같고 그리고 저는
어느 정도 시점이 되면 이런 세금
이슈라는 이런 대출 이슈라는 이런게
없어질 가능성도 있다라고
생각하거든요이 주거형 부동산이 그때
되면 아마 각광을 더 많이 받을 것
같아요 뉴욕에서 봤었던 그런 오피스
리테일이 다 비어 있는 건물을
주거용으로 바꾸는 시기잖아요 지금
많이 바꾸고 있고 근데 그게
우리나라에도 곧 올 거 같습니다
기존에 우리나라의 지원원 그런 오피스
건물 아니면 이제 상가 건물들을 다
주거용으로 바꾸는 시기가 오지 않을까
생각을 합니다 우리 회사도 지금
준비를 하고 있거든요 그때 시점이
됐을 때 저희도 이제 주거용 부동산을
많이 개발할 예정이거든요 그래서
여러분들도이 주거용 부동산에 좀
관심을 가지셔야 돼요 글로벌 기업들이
들어온 이유가 있을 거 아니에요
세계에서 유일한 그 전세 때문에
억눌려 있던 그 월세에 대한 메리트가
되게 크거든요 그리고 우리나라 자체가
뭐 1인 가고도 늘어나지만 개인이
소유한 부동산이랑 아마 기업이 소유한
부동산이 이랑 차이가 많이 날 거예요
그래서 아무래도 기업이 소유한 거는
관리도 잘 돼 있고 체계적으로 돼
있고 그리고 소비자 입장에서도 기업이
소유한게 전세금 때일 일도 없고
보증금 때일 일도 없고 그래서 이쪽에
소비자들이 많이 선택할 거 같거든요
그러다 보면 임대료 수준이 더 많이
올라갈 겁니다 그래서요 사이에도
양극화는 되게 심해질 거예요 전체적인
시장을 봤을 때는 월 임대료가 더
높아질 것으로 예상이 되기 때문에
여러분들도이 주거용 부동산 투자를
조금 염두를 하실 필요가 있는 거
같습니다네 그래서 오늘 영상은
여기까지 하고요 빌딩은 역시 빌사남
[음악]